wow this december marks the first full
financial year for recruitment mentors
which is crazy so in this short video i
wanted to share some of the amazing
milestones and highlights from this year
whilst also saying a massive thank you
to everyone who's been part of our
journey today 2021 has been all about
turning an idea into building traction
and this is what traction looks like
in numbers
since we opened our community doors in
november 2020 we have welcomed
354 recruiters who have all joined us to
progress their careers we've partnered
with 35 recruitment companies since june
to support them in developing their
teams after launching our team
membership to our eight founding
agencies in april we've onboarded 95
mentors who have all either delivered
bite-sized sessions or live interactive
training sessions for all of our
recruiters to attend what this
accumulates to is 50 hours worth of l d
content and so far this year we posted
37 live training sessions and we now
have a number of recruiters who have
been with us and who we've supported for
over a year this is honestly
amazing none of this would have been
possible without the fantastic mentors
who have all been nothing short of
brilliant sharing their best tips and
advice on everything from winning
business managing counter offers and
building the ultimate day plan
everything we have done this year has
come from aiming to take a step closer
to our vision which at recruitment
mentors is to build the place that
enables recruitment professionals to
maximize their potential at every stage
of their recruitment career and this
year 2021 we have most certainly taken a
step closer to realizing our vision so a
massive thank you to every single
recruitment company every single
recruitment consultant that has
partnered with us this year given us a
chance and believed in what we're trying
to achieve
with recruitment mentors we have massive
plans next year to continue to level up
our learning platform to help even more
recruitment consultants progress their
careers without limits and we're even
looking to make our first hire shortly
it's very exciting i'm going into the
end of the year feeling positive
optimistic so really keep tuned a huge
thanks again to everyone that supported
us and you're going to see a lot more
from us in 2022